what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
last night we got marvel's what if
episode four and to me this was easily
the best episode by far well i shouldn't
say by far episode two with t'challa was
pretty good but to me this episode
really hooked me and drew me into what
if more than before and i actually think
that it's going to have some pretty big
implications not only for other what-if
episodes that are coming in the future
and some previous episodes but also to
the actual mcu specifically i think that
we might have just gotten a little bit
of a glimpse into what multiverse of
madness could be like i also think that
there is a big spider-man no way home
connection here which i'll talk about my
theory about this in a bit executive
producer brad winterbomb did say that it
is possible for these what-if characters
to cross into the main mcu now and he
has confirmed that these are canon these
episodes are canon to the actual mcu
it's just all part of the multiverse and
in fact when marvel studios promotes
these episodes of what if they actually
show the timeline from loki they show
the monitor that the tva had from loki
implying that this does exist in a
branch timeline from the sacred timeline
so all of these according to people from
marvel studios are canon and do exist
within the mcu now if they leave their
universe and cross into a live-action
universe will they become live-action
i'm not really sure one would assume but
marvel is throwing some different things
at us lately so who knows but like i
said i do have some theories about that
which i'll talk about in a few minutes
right after we talk about some big
points of this episode and if you enjoy
breakdowns and news and staying up to
date on the mcu be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so this episode is pretty dark
but i actually in particularly enjoyed
the storytelling i like the idea of an
absolute point in time that you cannot
change and if you try to change it and
somehow manage to do so the whole
universe that it exists in will be
destroyed i know it's dark and probably
weird but i did really enjoy all of the
scenes where doctor strange was trying
to bring back christine but couldn't we
are essentially exploring fate here
something that loki could not deal with
he could not handle that his fate was
controlled now unfortunately this is not
the tva trying to control the situation
because i firmly believe that doctor
strange could probably take on the tva
but instead it's much bigger than that
it's kind of an absolute universal law
literally the fate of their universe
relies on christine palmer dying and let
me answer a question that might clear up
a little bit of confusion i know a lot
of people have asking if this is such an
absolute point why didn't she have to
die in the live action doctor strange
and the answer is the absolute point was
different in the film since this episode
did not go down the same path that
doctor strange did a new absolute point
was established the absolute point in
the movie was the car crash that he got
into by himself where he lost the
ability to control the majority of his
hands and fingers therefore making it to
where he could no longer do surgery
which would eventually lead him to seek
out ways to try and fix his hands which
would eventually lead him to find the
ancient one in the mystic arts and from
there we know what happens he goes on to
defeat dormammu and save the universe he
also goes on to save the universe or at
least half of it again in infinity war
and in-game so losing control of his
hands was the absolute point in the
movie but this what if episode asks what
if he didn't lose his hands but lost the
love of his life it seems like in any
universe that there is the main thing
that has to happen is doctor strange has
to find the mystic arts he has to meet
the ancient one and become the sorcerer
supreme if not a whole bunch of
destructive things could happen like
dormammu coming and doctor strange not
being there then durham mambu basically
destroying the universe so strange has
to be led to seek the mystic arts so
there has to be an absolute point in
each universe that leads him to seek
that and unfortunately in this what if
universe it's christine palmer dying and
no matter what he does he cannot undo
this and the ancient one comes and tells
him that if he does it will be the
destruction of this universe but it's
doctor strange he doesn't really care he
just wants to get the love of his life
back and he believes that if he can just
get more powerful and get more
knowledgeable he can bring her back and
as he turns out he was right but
unfortunately so was the ancient one and
it did lead to the destruction of his
universe now at the end of the episode
it is important to note that the
universe is indeed destroyed but it kind
of looks like doctor strange strange
supreme is in what is known in the
marvel comics as the void and i don't
actually think that he's gone in fact we
do have this image of him appearing in
another marvel what if episode alongside
peggy carter we also have the hyundai
commercial that was shown to us that
shows a big multiversal war at the end
what we believe to be the final episode
where different heroes from different
universes come together to fight ultron
we know in one episode ultron is going
to obtain all of the infinity stones so
he could pose a multiversal threat much
like kang and loki and all of these
what-if episodes may not appear to
connect right now but i do believe all
of them if not some of them are going to
be connecting at the end i'm thinking
the watcher might finally interfere when
ultron has threatened the existence of
the entire multiverse in which the
watcher has to bring together a bunch of
different heroes from a bunch of
different universes to fight ultron and
he himself even intervenes as we see in
this commercial also not to mention in
this episode we did see the hydra from
episode one who i do believe is
shumagorth and schumachureth is rumored
to be appearing in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness now a big question
is is this the exact same hydra from
episode one that captain carter fought
and the answer actually could be yes we
see that doctor strange actually did not
kill schumachorth he simply cut off some
of the tentacles absorb the tentacles
and harness their power and this is
rather interesting considering the fact
that every other being that we saw he
completely absorbed and you also have to
take into account that while strange is
absorbing these beings they mentioned
that it takes place over centuries this
is hundreds of years so depending on
when exactly this takes place in time
this very well could be the same being
that captain carter fights in episode 1.
now strange is only able to become this
powerful and absorb all of these beings
because he searched for cagliostro now
he learned about cagliostro before when
he was doing his research in the sanctum
and we have actually seen the book of
cagliostro in doctor strange cagliastro
was a very ancient sorcerer and
cagliostra was a very powerful sorcerer
indeed in one point in time in the
comics he actually taught dr doom and
sidenote i hope we do see this book in
multiverse of madness and i do hope that
somewhat sets up doom to make his mcu
debut because the book already does
exist in the mcu which means cagliostro
does now this book is very powerful in
some ways it could actually be stronger
than the darkhold that's because it's
actually accumulation of knowledge
knowledge taken from the darkhold
knowledge taken from other sorcerers as
well and of course cagliostro himself so
when the ancient one tries to stop
doctor strange and he tries to teleport
away he goes to where he's read
cagliestro's library might actually be
now in this process we learned that the
ancient one actually split doctor
strange into two two timelines in one
universe in which we end up with a good
or light doctor strange and a bad or
dark doctor strange and he's not
necessarily bad he just does bad things
to try and get the love of his life back
so the good doctor strange goes on to
really not tamper with time and he
decides to not try and bring christine
back he doesn't want to risk the fate of
the universe but the other goes on and
he does indeed find cagliostro he goes
on to meet obang and obeng is just
another name that kagliostro goes by in
the comics believed to be his original
name that he was given so he has scored
strange to the library of the lost books
and we see what i believe is the world
tree yidrasil you know the tree from
captain america the first avenger where
red skull found the tesseract hidden in
i think this could be that tree strains
ends up finding the book of cagliostro
and it looks pretty much identical to
the one that we saw in the mcu this is
the forbidden book and doctor strange
that he took to learn about time travel
and he learned about the eye of agamotto
and we got that apple scene from doctor
strange and the same thing happens here
in what if this book teaches him more
about time travel he opens it and it has
the same dark mark on it that the book
does in the movie that kaiselius has as
well again it's a very powerful book but
also a very dark book and this
definitely contributes to doctor
strange's dark side in this episode from
here he begins to absorb many mystical
beings and some of these aren't really
from the comics i can't really recognize
a lot of them if you recognize them be
sure to leave those in the comments down
below some of them look like just basic
mythology gods the gnome that he absorbs
in the beginning is actually from asgard
and when they show us these very very
quick glances of what he's kind of
becoming as he absorbs different
creatures it kind of looks like he does
indeed absorb mephisto at one point in
time but it's not that clear it also
looks like he possibly absorbs nightmare
at the same time as well as later on
when he goes to fight himself it looks
like he uses some nightmare abilities
after he absorbs all the monsters he
goes to cogliestro who we see is dying
and strange is about to reverse time for
him saving his life but he stops him and
here we learned that while strange was
doing all this he was actually kind of
frozen in time cagliustro said you used
magic to remain frozen for centuries so
all of this took place literally over
hundreds of years and this is kind of
ironic because in the comics cagliustro
is the one that essentially became
immortal now from there cagliostro tells
him that there are two doctor stranges
he was split and he won't be strong
enough until he is whole meanwhile the
ancient one tells the other doctor
strange essentially the same thing she
split him and now the other one is
threatening to destroy the universe and
the destruction of the universe has
already begun to happen now from here
the two stranges fight one to save the
universe one to save the love of his
life and strange supreme using all the
abilities of all of the beings that he
absorbed ends up defeating the good
doctor strange he absorbs him and he
becomes powerful enough to stop that
absolute point in time where christine
palmer had to die as i mentioned before
strange was right he was able to undo it
but also the ancient one was right as
well and this eventually leads to the
destruction of the universe however not
before the watcher comes into play and
this is the first time that we see the
watcher interact with somebody as the
universe collapses and everyone not just
christine is about to die strange begs
the watcher for help says that he's read
about him and he sensed his presence the
watcher appears and he tells him that he
cannot interfere this is what watchers
are tasked to do they observe and they
report they are all powerful and even
though he says that he's not a god he
does have the ability to undo it but he
says that he can't and doctor strange is
a perfect example of why he can't he
says meddling with time and events only
leads to more destruction he then leaves
and the universe gets destroyed and this
is confirmed by the watchers narrative
after where he says one life one choice
one moment can destroy the entire
universe and that's the episode but i do
not believe that we have seen the end of
strange supreme i actually think that he
could or at least a version of him
appear in spider-man no way home
obviously a lot of people have been able
to tell that there seems to be something
up with doctor strange in the no way
home trailer and while i do actually
personally think that it's the normal
strange he's just kind of arrogant like
he's always been maybe even more
arrogant now since he's learned a lot of
magic in the meantime and you know
essentially saved half of the universe i
still think that we could see the
strange supreme the one that we saw in
this what if aside of him in doctor
strange in this episode of what if
strange was split into two one of them
listened to wong's warnings and he did
not go on to try and undo this absolute
point in time the other one dr strange
did and this kind of seems like that
part in the no way home trailer where
wang says strange don't do that spell
and of course strange doesn't listen and
he does it anyways which ends up causing
the multiverse to essentially crack open
which is kind of what happens in what if
strange ignores wong and that decision
led to the destruction of the universe
and i believe that this is something
very similar to what we'll see in
spider-man no way home strange ignores
wong there is big multiversal
repercussions and strange kind of
becomes strange supreme i do think there
is the possibility that this could
actually be the exact same strange this
does take place previously before the
events of spider-man no way home and far
from home and avengers infinity war and
end game and we don't really know the
multiversal repercussions of what if yet
so i think there is a chance that this
could actually be the same doctor
strange that we see in spider-man no way
home but be sure to let me know your
thoughts on this theory in the comments
down below and also be sure to let me
know what you rate this episode 1 out of
10 in the comments as well again if you
love marvel and want to stay up to date
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and don't forget to
like the video and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof
you